new york city is one of the most
expensive places in the country whether
it's worth it is another question but it
is it's very expensive to buy
a place there but don't ask the people
who want to be mayor of new york because
they have no idea
a couple of days ago the new york times
asked the candidates running for mayor
of new york city what the median
home price is in brooklyn
here's some of the guesses sean donovan
should
know he's a former city housing
commissioner he was literally barack
obama's secretary of housing and urban
development
in charge of houses his guess
quote somewhere in the 80 to 90
000 range well that's just a 900 000
off the median home price in brooklyn
almost 1 million dollars
but he wasn't the only one who was that
wrong
though it's the funniest ray mcguire
used to be an executive at citigroup he
guessed
it was a hundred thousand dollars and
that is the median price if it were
1980 things have changed in 40 years
affordable housing is a massive problem
for most people u.s home prices are up
over 10 percent from last year
in part because foreigners are dumping
their cash here
in real estate big companies are also
buying up a lot of houses you may not
have known that
we've seen the steepest gains in almost
a decade and a half
the responses from the candidates who
want to be mayor of new york tell us why
none of our leaders seem bothered to fix
this problem
they're not even aware it exists
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else